- This butterfly was once
thought to be extinct.
Though rediscovered, it
remains one of the world's
rarest and most elusive butterflies.
This is the Palos Verdes Blue Butterfly.
This butterfly is as
elusive as it is beautiful.
And the brilliance of its blue wings
are only visible when it opens them.
The wings are distinctive
with their brilliant silvery blue color.
The butterfly was thought
to be extinct in the 1980s,
when it seemed to
disappear without a trace.
It wasn't until the 1990s that
this visually striking
butterfly was spotted again.
Biologists were surprised and
delighted in its existence.
And a breeding program was
begun to build up the species.
Though captive breeding
has helped bolster numbers,
the population is still low enough
to remain on the endangered list.
Through careful nurturing and management,
this small but mighty butterfly
has a fighting chance.
This is the Palos Verdes Blue Butterfly.